.
TRACE?
>> Trace: WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU
AS THE NEWS BREAKS.
LET'S BRING IN KARL ROVE, FORMER
DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAND TO
PRESIDENT BUSH.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I'M READING THE SAME THING THAT
PETER WAS READING.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT WILL PROHIBIT TRADE
IN THE DNR AND LNR REGIONS OF
UKRAINE.
IS THAT STRONG ENOUGH, KARL?
YOU'RE PUTTING SANCTIONS ON THE
BREAK-AWAY REGIONS AND LEAVING
RUSSIA ALONE.
>> NO, IT'S NOT STRONG AT ALL.
IT'S LAUGHABLE.
THIS IS A MOMENT -- I HOPE THIS
ISN'T ALL THEY'RE GOING TO DO.
I HOPE THEY'RE AGREEING ON A SET
OF SANCTIONS THAT THEY CAN
ANNOUNCE THAT IF VLADIMIR PUTIN
DOES SIGN THE DOCUMENT,
RECOGNIZING THIS BREAK-AWAY
REGION AS AN INDEPENDENT REGION
AND COMMITTING TO RUSSIAN
PEACEKEEPERS, THAT SOME SERIOUS
SANCTIONS WILL BE PUT IN FORCE.
THIS IS THE PRELIMINARY.
THIS IS THE OPENING ACT OF AN
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
REMEMBER, THESE TWO REGIONS,
LESS THAN A THIRD OF THOSE
REGIONS ARE NOW UNDER CONTROL OF
THE SEPARATISTS.
SO WHAT THE RUSSIANS ARE
ATTEMPTING TO DO IS RECOGNIZE
THESE REPUBLICS, GIVE THEM
ADDITIONAL MILITARY SUPPORT AND
INVADE THE UKRAINIAN TERRITORY
TO TAKE THE OTHER 2/3s OF THE
STATES IN THE EASTERN PART OF
UKRAINE AWAY FROM THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT AND PUT THEM UNDER
CONTROL OF MOSCOW.
THIS IS A PRETENSE TO INVASION,
PRETEXT.
WE OUGHT TO RESPOND STRONGLY TO
IT.
>> Trace: YOU MAKE A VERY GOOD
POINT.
UKRAINIAN ARMY FORCES CONTROL
SIGNIFICANT CHUNKS OF THESE TWO
TERRITORIES.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS SOUND BITE
FROM JOHN KIRBY AND JAKE
SULLIVAN.
>> WE'RE ABSOLUTELY PREPARED TO
SIT DOWN AND SERIOUSLY DISCUSS
WITH MR. PUTIN A DIPLOMATIC WAY
FORWARD HERE.
>> WE WILL NOT CLOSE THE DOOR ON
DIPLOMACY.
WE WILL GO THE EXTRA MILE.
WE'RE ALSO PREPARED TO RESPOND
DECISIVELY.
>> SURE FEELS LIKE THAT DOOR IS
GETTING NEAR THE HOLE CLOSING,
KARL.
>> AT SOME POINT IT WILL.
FRANKLY, I THINK THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT BY PUTIN TO LAY WHAT HE
CONSIDERS TO BE A QUASI LEGAL
PREDICATE FOR THE INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY MEASURE.
HE WILL RECOGNIZE TWO BREAK-AWAY
REPUBLICS THAT NOBODY ELSE IN
THE WORLD RECOGNIZES, THAT DON'T
CONTROL ALL OF THE TERRITORY AND
THEY'LL ASK FOR RUSSIA TROOPS TO
COME IN AND THE RUSSIANS WILL BE
IN ESSENCE INVADING THE
TERRITORY OF AN INDEPENDENT
COUNTRY, UKRAINE.
IF WE DON'T RECOGNIZE THAT FOR
WHAT IT IS, WHICH IS AN INVASION
AND TAKE TOUGH STEPS IN
RESPONSE, WE WILL SEE MORE
ACTIVITY ON THE PART OF PUTIN.
NOT LESS.
IT'S WEAK FOR THE UNITED STATES
TO SAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW
ANYBODY INTO -- TO INVEST THE
EASTERN REGION OF UKRAINE THAT
WILL SHORTLY BE UNDER RUSSIAN
CONTROL.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Trace: AND LASTLY, I MEAN,
THE E.U. SOUNDS VERY MUCH LIKE
WITH NATO.
THEY ARE AGAINST RUSSIA.
THEY ARE ALIGNED AND THEY'RE NOT
BUDGING AT ALL.
BUT WILL THAT LAST?
IF THIS THINGS TAKES ANOTHER TEN
DAYS TO GET THESE TROOPS IN
THERE, KARL, WILL THIS ALLIANCE
STAY INTACT?
>> I THINK THE RUSSIANS HAVE
MISCALCULATED.
I THINK NATO HAS BEEN
STRENGTHENED BY THIS.
THEY RECOGNIZE THE THREAT OF
RUSSIA.
TAKE FINLAND, FOR EXAMPLE, WHICH
DURING THE ENTIRE COLD WAR ERA
WAS NEUTRAL BETWEEN THE WEST AND
RUSSIA.
THE LEADER OF FINLAND NOW SAYS
THAT IF UKRAINE IS INVADED,
FINLAND WILL CONSIDER ASKING FOR
MEMBERSHIP IN NATO BECAUSE HE
SAID OUR ORIENTATION IS TOWARDS
THE WEST AND WE WILL CONDEMN AN
INVASION OF UKRAINE AS -- BY
RUSSIA AS A HOSTILE ACT ALONG AN
INDEPENDENT COUNTRY.
THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY.
A LOT OF EUROPEAN CAPITOLS ARE
RECOGNIZING PUTIN FOR WHAT HE
IS, WHICH IS A THUG AND THEY
WILL NOT STAND FOR THE INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
THEY'LL SEE IT AS A THREAT